welcome to the coding portions of lesson
3 in this lesson we're going to learn
how to use object if I save entities in
the datastore we're going to use
entities of kind profile to save user
profile information and we're going to
learn how to get the user ID of the
logged in user to use it to generate a
unique ID for the entities key once
we've created some data and safety in
the datastore we're going to use the
datastore viewer in the admin console to
look at the data that we've saved make
sure it's safe like we thought it would
and there's no point putting data into
the datastore if you can't get it back
out so then we're going to learn how to
get an entity out of the datastore if
you know it's key let's go create some
profiles